so you've been learning a language for a
while and you've got this horrible
feeling that you're not making progress
anymore try as you might there's a
single thought you can't get out of your
head i feel stuck
if you're in the situation you might be
wondering how i can get unstuck and
start making progress again lucky for
you
i know just the solution and even better
i've got a special surprise for you that
will help you implement the solution
into your language learning so you will
never ever get stuck again just remember
to stay tuned until the very end of this
video
hi i'm luca from lucarameter.com and i'm
an italian language coach who currently
speaks 14 languages and i help people
learn languages better faster and in a
smart way so as i was saying there's one
point in the language learning journey
where even the most serious language
learners get stuck a place where despite
their best efforts progress just doesn't
seem to come as easily as it used to
this is a place most language learners
call the intermediate plateau we call it
a plateau because it's one of the first
places on your language learning journey
where progress becomes virtually flat
it's not like the beginner stages where
you're seemingly learning new things
every time you sit down to learn nor is
it like the advanced stages where
learning feels easy like you're just
filling in the gaps if you're stuck at
the intermediate plateau learning feels
difficult and slow you're not seeing
easy daily progress and you don't feel
confident enough yet to go out and make
friends read books or watch tv shows or
movies comfortably but let me quickly
teach you something that most people do
not know about the intermediate plateau
it has a lot to do with your language
learning comfort zone when you first
started learning a language everything
was fresh and everything was new because
you were learning basic words and
phrases everything felt risk-free and
relatively easy as time went on
everything that once felt new suddenly
felt comfortable you could understand a
few things say a few things usually just
enough to feel competent at the things
you wanted to do and because you felt
competent a certain range of learning
activities became your comfort zone this
is probably where you are now there's an
expression that goes what got you here
won't get you there in a language
learning context it means that to move
beyond where you are now you need to
change how you do things and to move
beyond the intermediate plateau you
specifically need to change how you go
about practicing your target language
you need to move beyond what i call
simple practice to a more challenging
type of practice called deliberate
practice
deliberate practice is a research-backed
form of skill development that involves
breaking down skills into their
essential components recognizing and
addressing your weak points and then
rebuilding that skill a new
than it was before language learning is
at its core a set of skills so if you
can learn how to break down and rebuild
your skills in this way you can learn to
stretch your capabilities beyond your
comfort zone and finally get out of the
intermediate plateau take for example my
deliberate practice based approach to
improving my speaking skills this is an
activity i only engage in when i'm
around the intermediate level usually
three to six months after i started
learning a language the first thing i do
is find a reliable native speaker that i
can regularly talk to most of the time i
use a service like itoki to hire a tutor
that i can speak to every week most
people would stop here they talk to the
tutor a couple of times a week about
anything and everything maybe get some
feedback and then
they probably never think about that
session ever again that's simple
practice which again won't get you where
you want to go to deliberately practice
my speaking skills i schedule regular
30-minute sessions with a tutor usually
once or twice a week prepare exactly
what i want to talk about before every
session including coming up with a list
of words or key phrases that i want to
use i direct the conversation towards
the topic and ideas i prepare for i ask
for specific kinds of feedback tailored
to the exact aspects of my speaking
skills that i want to improve i record
the entire session with permission of
course and save it for later reviews in
the days after the session i re-listen
to the conversation and note anything
important i want to memorize or address
in later tutoring sessions as you can
see this process is much more involved
than a typical tutoring session
but i found that it is exactly what i
and other learners need to push their
speaking skills beyond the intermediate
plateau and towards fluency and although
this is a process i designed just for
speaking the rules of deliver practice
can be applied to all of the other
language skills as well like listening
reading writing even grammar and
pronunciation if you want your language
skills to survive beyond the plateau
this is the kind of action you need to
be ready to take you need to narrow your
focus on specific skills break them down
fix them and build them back again if
you watch this far you might be saying
but luca i'm a busy person how can i do
all that all by myself when i've never
even reached fluency in a language
before
well that's why i'm here after spending
over 30 years learning languages and
more than 10 years coaching others to
learn them i visited the intermedia
plaza again and again i've learned it's
ins and outs i know where the pitfalls
lie and i've got it others safely past
them simply put as a speaker of 14
languages i can show you the way beyond
the intermediate plateau so that even if
you've ever stuck there again you'll
know just how to get unstuck and find a
way through and now for the surprise i
mentioned at the very beginning as i
said i know just the right strategies to
help you overcome the intermediate
plateau for your current target language
and any language you might learn in the
future
and i want to teach them to you not just
one or two strategies but all of them
and i plan to do that through my brand
new six week webinar course titled
overcoming the intermediate plateau this
will be a six week webinar-based course
where you will work directly with me my
team and other like-minded language
learners to help take your existing
language skills and bring them beyond
the dreaded intermediate plateau to the
point where you can use your target
language at a fluent conversational
level these are powerful methods that
will challenge your skills and give you
structure and direction at a time when
language learning progress is slow and
hardest to see if you master these
methods you will have everything you
need to finally become fluent just like
you've always dreamed of
but don't take my word for it here's
what some of my students have to say
about the very same methods you will be
learning in these webinars hi my name is
brian i am not a polyglot uh in fact
french is the first language that i've
been tackling as an adult
and i'm probably about the
a2 b1 level right now been studying for
about a year
and i want to tell you a little bit
about uh
my impressions of working with luca so
before luca i spent probably the first
eight months of this year trying a
variety of different methods
some focused on speaking right away
more grammar study based others using
prepared stories and dialogues tons of
different apps
but what i think
luca offers that's really separates
himself from the pack is
that he has a really sound understanding
of
language learning theory and then on top
of this theory he's built really
effective tools so uh his language
learning theory is distinct from some of
these other approaches and that
he understands that the research shows
the best way to learn languages is more
like how a child's orange learns
language by exposure to comprehensible
input in that in the target language um
and
this tends to work a lot better than
just learning a bunch of grammar rules
or vocab lists and then trying to apply
that knowledge
um so so that's first but then using
this theory uh he's built a bunch of
really effective practical tools that
will help you know exactly what to do
every day when you sit down to do your
language work
whether you're studying for 15 minutes a
day or an hour a day or more
and they scale really nicely from the
beginning stages all the way up to
advanced stages
and also they really allow you to use
all this amazing free content on the
internet um to to center your language
studies around uh and plus they're just
a ton of fun um so
my experience so far with luca for the
last several months has been amazing my
french has been
getting better very quickly and and i've
been having a lot of fun at it uh so
it's my opinion that if you've come
across luca's content i think you should
consider yourself really lucky and just
uh just go for it just go ahead and work
with him
so i just want to say thanks to luca for
sharing all this wonderful knowledge uh
with the rest of us
hi my name is uh george dick um a couple
of weeks ago i planted a couple of
cherry trees in our yard and later was
having a conversation with somebody
about fruit trees in general and he said
the best time to plant a fruit tree is
10 years ago the second best time is
right now
and that's really how i feel about
working with luca
i can't even imagine the kind of
progress i would have made in my last 30
years of studying languages on and off
if i had been working with luca in his
methodologies
um i really started working with luca as
a coach about a year ago i think
and um the amount of progress i've been
able to make in just a year compared to
the amount of things that i did that
weren't particularly effective over the
previous years is is just amazing
whether it's starting a language from
scratch or working up to something i'm
about to take the c1 exam um in a few
weeks for spanish finally
and i think i'm gonna pass we'll see
um but the the strategies that he has
for
getting better at speaking getting
better at writing or just just
astounding um and whatever service that
he puts together is just something i
would jump at the opportunity to work
with
um
i'm so glad that i found luca when i did
and i hope that you
take advantage of his methods sooner
rather than later because you just will
be thrilled with the impact that he's
able to have on your
language learning adventures
thanks a lot bye-bye
these words fill me with joy they're
proof that when you're armed with the
right mindset and the right tools
anything is possible that's why i'm so
excited to release this live course i
can finally share my intermediate level
language learning techniques and
strategies with many more people than i
could ever do in a one-on-one coaching
session
and if you think each of these webinars
sounds exciting wait until you hear
about all the extras you will be
receiving as well beyond the six two
hour webinars of the course in fact you
will receive access to our two weekly
one-hour group calls with me to ask
questions and share your progress access
to our learner community and circle so
you can interact with dedicated learners
just like you weekly missions along with
pdf guides that will teach you how to
tailor the course techniques to specific
languages monthly q a sessions with me
and by team and so much more
best of all if you join the six week
course you'll automatically gain access
to our video based online version of the
same course when we release it next year
so what do you think you now know
everything you need to know about my
brand new overcoming the intermediate
plateau live course are you finally
ready to conquer the intermediate
plateau and reach the fluency you have
always wanted there will be only 100
seats available for this webinar series
and that will be filled on a first come
first served basis without exception so
if you're interested please check and
click the link on the description box
below to learn more about how you can
sign up i cannot wait to see you in the
course
happy language learning and talk to you
soon
[Music]
you